[Music]
so there are going to be two
boyfriends living in the house we're
terrified our kids are going
to be
molested the idea that because they are
all dating
means they're more likely to sexually as
assault and molest a child isn't
accurate
[Music]
what's up this is john with the dr john
dolone's show
so glad that you're with us
hope the sun is shining or it's raining
whichever one you need i hope your
family's doing well hope you're doing
well the greatest mental health podcast
that has ever existed
it says my mom
and my my children
my children don't say that
man i hope you're doing well hey i'd
love to have you on the show
we got people calling in and writing in
from all over the planet it's super rad
if you want to be on the show give me a
buzz at 1-844-693-3291
it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask a s
k
we got joseph on the board back here
today
it's good to see you man
i can't i keep thinking this show can't
possibly get handsomer and then joe
shows up although he's wearing an
alabama hat i'm not gonna say anything
negative about alabama because they will
ring down
like there'll be picket lines out in the
lobby that won't go well for me it's
good to see you man good to see you all
right let's go to the phones let's go to
jordan in houston my hometown
go astros what's up jordan
hey john not much how are you doing we
are partying that's not true i'm not
partying at all actually um i'm sitting
at a desk talking on the phone
hey there's four awesome people from all
over america out here watching too we
have a packed studio audience here what
are you up to
uh just uh hanging out and excited to
talk to you so very cool i guess i can
just kind of go ahead and
kind of get going here and let you know
what i'm calling about yeah tell me
what's up um
so here's where i'm at i kind of just
want to see if you can help guide me in
the right direction um in my past i've
just never been very good with friends
friends has never been my strong point
um i know exactly for me kind of where
the issue started when i was young um
but that kind of helps you a little bit
absolutely
if you do i mean do you kind of want to
know like where it kind of started for
me
yeah before we do that let's do this um
when you say
um so you you and i talked a little bit
earlier for a minute before we had and
we had to reshoot some stuff you were
mentioning that you you have friends and
you start friendships and they end in
ash what does that mean
so for me it means that they end in ash
i
and this is why i'm in therapy now this
is why i'm working on this but it ends
up being that i end up
abruptly ending the friendship there's
no reconciliation there's no nothing i'm
just i think too scared to kind of
get if that makes sense do you end it
over an issue like somebody's like hey i
got vaccinated and you're like you're an
idiot i hate you
or do you just wake up on a tuesday and
you're like
you're lame it's kind of it's kind of
like it'll build up over time and i
never really say anything about it
what builds up
so
uh
i mean i'll take my most i think shining
example of this
i had a 10-year friendship right
this
i ended up living with this girl we were
friends since high school it was really
awesome you know i ended up moving to
texas and living with her for a while
ended up meeting my husband everything
like that like texas is great right so
over the time that we had lived together
the environment that i was living in
with her just became
really unsafe really unstable really
scary um what does that mean and then
so like for instance one of the
roommates uh
threatened to shoot up drug dealers and
then the drug dealers came back and said
we're going to shoot everyone in your
entire house
so kind of thing so sometimes i talk to
folks they're like it's just not safe
there's cheetos everywhere
and
then there's
uh it's not safe because someone's gonna
murder us so okay so you're this is
legitimate not safe okay
right and so it kind of ended up being
and in the middle of this i was planning
my wedding right so i had a lot going on
yeah
so my now husband and i ended up moving
out of this house we you know got out of
there we're safe no one was harmed thank
goodness um and then it ended up being
that
she was trying to control planning my
wedding
and i
and i think i just got to a point where
i just couldn't handle her anymore
and it was like less than a month before
my wedding ended up cutting the
friendship off no nothing no
i just said i can't i can't have you in
my life anymore and i just cut her off
so did you uninvite her from your
wedding
she was going to be my bridesmaid one of
my bridesmaids
you just broke up with her
i 100 yeah i just broke up with her and
it makes me sad to this day like i've
written like a letter that i haven't
sent you know like
that kind of stuff but i think what i'm
just scared of now and here's where i am
now is that i've made a new friend and
i'm scared of this happening again like
i'm scared of
repeating history you know yeah
so
take me back quickly take me back to you
said you knew where this stuff all comes
from
where does it come from so
you were right so it started when i was
i believe i was like 10 right so i went
to a uh 4-h camp over the summer one
year 4-h camp chickens and goats
everywhere
no it was like a 4-h camp like we were
hiking and then we would like uh go
swimming
it was kind of one of those camps okay
um
so what ended up happening was i was
friends with these two girls like we
went to camp we met we like hung out
we were supposed to go to a dance one
night and um we like that morning we
were all like kind of coordinating our
outfits like we were like this is gonna
be fun and we were excited and
everything
we went to dinner
before the dance and the two girls
came up to me like i couldn't find them
for some reason and they come up to me
randomly
and they both together said every other
word of one sentence so if you can kind
of picture that in your head
they said one sentence but each girl was
saying one word was it like going back
and forth
so they came up to me and they said we
don't want to be your friend anymore we
don't want to hang out with you anymore
we don't want to go to the dance with
you
and in that moment i'm like
of course i was upset like i like you
know cried and everything like i was ten
i don't know you know like you were dead
yeah and then um that's kind of where it
started
where what started
where i think my issues with friendships
really started
i would be willing to bet money i'm not
very wealthy i'm not wealthy at all i'd
be willing to bet you that's not where
it started
um
my guess is if you and i sat down and
kind of put that may be a contributing
factor
kids are wildly resilient
those kind of things can be a thorn
um
but
all that to say is this
understanding
like to use the language from the book
owning what happened owning the fact
that you have a history of either
friends breaking up with you or you
breaking up with friends
okay
that's the important part there
that you recognize you want to be in
relationship with people and somehow it
always implodes
and now we're at a stage where we have
to acknowledge reality you have found
yourself relatively alone
and you found yourself always something
happens in these friendships
um
how truthful can i be with you can it be
super truthful
that's why i called okay yeah
whenever somebody calls me usually this
call is about dating right i i date i've
dated 10 people and it always blows up
spectacularly whatever my question is
always
you're the common denominator in all 10
of these relationships
what are you bringing to the table so i
would ask you that in this similar
situation because at the end of the day
you can't control these other people in
your life what are you bringing to the
table that is making these relationships
extra combustible or
um
what are you bringing to the table
that puts this pressure on a
relationship to exist or not exist
um
that's a really good question i think um
because here's what i don't want you to
do i don't want you to keep looking at
the finish line because there's not a
finish line with friendships or the
finish line is death okay
and
friendships take a
an up and down all over the place
roll depending on what season you're in
some of my closest friends on the planet
during i've been
traveling all over the country speaking
at companies and events and things like
that i just don't see my friends very
much we text and then when i'm home i
see them much more regularly
and i was just visiting some guys that
um i haven't seen in several years and
we picked up and we were running around
this dude's ranch in texas
we picked up just like it was yesterday
right but now we're just older and more
wrinkled and dumber and then right so
some of it's about season but
so i don't want you to focus on the
metric
i just want you to focus on
the connectivity what are you bringing
to that connectivity
that makes you feel like this thing's
going to always end in ash which then
certifies this i mean assures that it's
always getting into nash
i think what i'm bringing to the table
is the expectation that it's going to at
some point
honestly um
i i think i just kind of expect it to
end at some point and i
yeah i mean it's sorry i wish i had a
better answer i'm like i'm stuck
actively thinking about this
that's a great thing so you've probably
heard this analogy there's a there's a
bow hunting an archery analogy that um
comes from skiing
when when you have those downhill skiers
that are running through the forest
you have to you can't look at the trees
because if you look at the trees you'll
hit them every time you have to look at
the space between the trees and that's
how those skiers fly through those those
forests
and when you're doing archery or your
bow hunting you can't look at the limbs
and try not to hit the limbs you have to
look zero in on your target
and that's how you
right so you go through all stuff if you
head into new friendships head into new
relationships and by the way your
husband is a friendship of some sort and
my guess is he's probably put this
burden on him too
looking forward
is that true
i wish it wasn't but i think part like
in the back of my head i keep thinking
okay like he's gonna leave me eventually
or you know something like that i know
that won't happen or i hope it doesn't
happen but i don't
you know what i mean yeah um
besides those friends who who who took
off on you
besides knuckleheads at a camp who took
off on you
um
no one
no one really left me per se i mean i
know i grew up in a household but there
was a lot of yelling let me let me back
up the other side someone doesn't have
to leave you who didn't welcome you
because there's trauma can be both
what what somebody said to you what they
did to you but it can also be what
didn't happen to you
somebody should have told you this house
only runs because you're in it someone
should have told you
um
i love you
and i'm glad you're my kid
yeah no one ever really told me that i
mean i i god i love you a lot but i
never really got like i'm grateful
you're here i never really got like
you're you're a essential part of this
household i grew up with a lot of
yelling um so let's not necessarily at
me but watching like my dad yell at my
sister growing up that was really hard
yeah and for a kid you can hear the
words i love you and your body can react
to the unsafe environment with which you
live and that creates chaos
right right and so that chaos ping-pongs
through every relationship you're going
to have so your choice now is this
is to say okay those things happened
what am i going to do now
and what i would tell you is it sounds
like when playing semantics and i'm not
there the the difference between how
incredible can me and my husband make
our marriage
versus how do i keep from losing this
thing
one of those is a performance and a
checklist and a set of metrics
the other
is a free-for-all
into a new adventure you see what i'm
saying now that new adventure is going
to be filled with potholes and routes
that you trip on and metrics that you
need to keep up with but it's it's it's
the other way around and i would tell
you that with friendships
entering into a friendship with
expectations that this is all going to
come down someday
it's like dude we're just getting coffee
you know what i mean right um yeah and
when a friend lets you down which a
hundred percent of them will
and i have let my friends down
the relationship it's
if you go looking for when does this end
you will find confirmation of the ending
everywhere
if you go into
like
we're just we just ride or die this is
just who we are
there will become seasons when you'll
when you all fade out and that's okay
and then there'll be seasons like we're
just not friends and you're like oh man
we've been hung out in three years
that's just that's just how life works
but there's always gonna be a core group
of people that you circle back to and
you circle back to because you're
intentional about it and when they let
you down then you can have that hard
conversation hey you were taking over my
wedding stop
you're my friend
and then they might say
you're a
train wreck
you're always playing playing things and
it's a mess and we're staring so here's
the example in my wedding you ready um
i
was real against like i don't want any
of my friends have to spend any money so
i was like we're not doing tuxes we're
not doing internet stuff i want y'all
just to wear clothes that you already
have and so i came up with these outfits
that were like white shirts and and like
short sleeve shirts because it was hot
outside in texas where i got married and
like khaki pants everybody's got that
and a group of my buddies
came and two of them in particular said
hey by the way we've all changed what
we're wearing because you have us
dressed like idiots we're not doing this
and um by the way you're gonna go get a
jacket too because you're not a [ __ ]
you're getting married so
here's the thing
i wasn't waiting for them to screw up so
that i could announce i knew it my
friendship's over
i i said hey i want to do it differently
and they said we love you enough that 20
years from now when your kids look back
at those pictures they're going to have
less respect for you because you made us
dressed like morons and so uh we love
you enough to hold you accountable to it
and i went thank y'all thank you you
know what i mean and so there's a moment
when you can say hey you're taking over
my wedding and your friend can say
that's because it's a mess and it's
gonna go
horribly awry or
i'm sorry right you see what i'm saying
because there's not all that pressure
there's not a finish line that we're
looking to get to so here let me say
this um you said you have a new friend
tell me about this new friend
uh she's awesome we uh
we have a lot in common we're both
tattooed so that's cool um we both have
dogs we both don't have kids yet you
know we're both
fairly young marriages um
that kind of thing we both i mean we've
been kind of like confiding in each
other a little bit like we've been we've
been finding those uh
areas in our life where it's like
me too you know what i mean and so
that's been kind of nice to have that
person in that way so that's it's it's
been great i mean it's only been a
couple of months but i mean
do you feel the pressure you're putting
on this already
i do like you've created a checklist for
it already so let me be like
um i have tattoos i just don't have i
have them under my clothes right so you
can't see them
and i've got friends who are tatted
tattooed all over the place and i've got
great friends that have zero and they
make fun of me
and i've got friends does that make
sense
so what i would tell you is
instead of looking for a bunch of oh
yeah me too oh yeah me too oh yeah me
too
ask yourself how your body feels in
their company
okay ask yourself like when i say
something
kind of vulnerable to this person i feel
safe or i
don't feel comfortable
that's a totally different question then
oh look we have the same shoes oh look
we have the same hair oh look we have
this like that's a recipe for disaster
because there's gonna come a point when
the next election rolls around and
you're like i'm super voting for so and
so and she'll be like i'm voting for
this person and you're like there it is
the end
and you'll be like son of a and then
it's going to be over to be a bit don't
do
if she's your friend you can be like oh
man
i think you're an idiot and she'll be
like nah you're the idiot and y'all can
have a discussion and then you can have
some more nachos you see what i'm saying
yeah i do so let me say this
all all relationship 100 of them
is a risk
i don't care if you're 85 and you've
been married for 40 years
40 years in one day when you tell your
husband hey i was hoping we could travel
here
and he might say i ain't traveling where
don't you know the liberals or whatever
he's gonna say
um
you just took a risk and you got shot
down
right you're 80. and you're running into
the last years of your life and you just
want to go see what san francisco looks
like and my husband ain't taking you
that right you just run into that that's
a risk it's always a risk
meeting new friends is always a risk it
just is and so what i would tell you and
if nobody has ever told you this i'm
sorry i hate that i'm the first one
you're worth being friends with
and you're going to be a i promise you
jordan you're a weirdo everybody is
and
somebody will be friends with your
little weirdos
and or they'll put up with your
weirdoness and you'll put up with their
weirdoness
but trying to perform and checklist your
way through a series of friendships is a
fool's errand it's going to end in ash
every time so the
i'm kind of on a kick lately
um and it started with me just changing
my diet up some and i'll talk about that
in a future episode but here's what i
would i would challenge you on
you've done friendships this way how old
are you now
i just turned 30. okay
20 plus years this is how you've done
friendships
yeah i want to challenge you
to look in your around your environment
and acknowledge reality this is where
you've landed with basically zero and
your husband
let's commit to trying something
different
okay let's commit to stop looking for
the ending
when you find yourself tell like saying
he's probably just gonna leave
stop that thought say no no stop stop
stop he's not leaving he's my husband
and then be curious about why am i
saying that
what is it about my day
what's going on in my life when i start
to say things like that is it when he's
busy or is it when i
um
want to sleep together and he's
playing video games as friends and i
started is it when bills are due is it
when i'm hungry is it when i'm tired
start asking yourself when did these
negative thoughts come into my head
and stop them before they come stories
because when they become stories then
your body responds with the cascaded
chemicals now you're off to the races
and so let's stop them way up ahead and
always know i'm worth being friends with
and this person that your friend like
she may become your best friend of all
time ever or she just may be a great
human being in this season and then
y'all will both get get pregnant and
you'll be like oh gosh you're one of
those moms
and she's gonna be like oh my gosh she's
one of those moms and then you're gonna
find another gang right you see what i'm
saying
yeah take the pressure off
here's what i'd love you to do um
go back through some people in your in
your friendships in the past that um
that you loved and that are quote
unquote in ash
see if there's one or two or three of
them you can pick up a phone and call
and don't facebook them
be have a human interaction but reach
out and
call and say hey let's go get coffee
and
or um let's go
x or y let's go do something and some of
those friendships those those old
friendships may need to the conversation
needs to start with i just need to start
this conversation by saying i'm sorry i
screwed that up
and i'm working through a lot of
childhood stuff
not an excuse it just happened i did it
and i was rude and i want to start fresh
or something i love you and i'm sorry i
don't hang out anymore but i miss you i
hope you're doing well
and
see what it feels like what it feels
like to go back and say the words i'm
sorry to go back to people that you have
deep roots with and say man we got off
sideways but this tree didn't fall all
the way over and uh let's hang out and
with this new friend
stop going to the checklist
just hang out man just hang out enjoy
your life enjoy your life enjoy your
husband y'all create something amazing
together don't try not to break up and i
hope you can tell the difference there
we'll be right back
[Music]
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to ann
and peter pan and st louis what's up ann
oh
not too much how we doing
i am okay
oh that usually means not not great
well
uh yes
so um
so good well i'm gonna come up with a
smart uh yeah not good all right so tell
me what's up
okay um
i'll give you a little bit of backstory
i'll try to make it as short as possible
um
my husband and i have been married um
almost five years
and um
when we married um i in i say i
inherited three kids um
when his previous wife left
she walked away not totally but mostly
and so
together we've been raising
what excuse me what what does that mean
totally but not mostly or mostly but not
totally um
okay so
with no warning like he thought they
were going to counseling they were
trying to work on things
um she
left okay like and couch hopped for two
years
so she would see the kids sometimes like
i mean she wasn't out of the town
she'd see them for like half an hour
sometimes
she just showed up
just in and out like a like a yeah
okay all right and but there was no
formal arrangement or formal agreement
or anything like that she just would
show up there is but it's never been
like we technically have joint custody
but it's a joke okay okay all right
um
okay so
um
so the kids were 12 10 and eight when we
got married
and their life shifted completely right
um like
in a healthier better way but still a
major change like
we used to have tvs in our room and
jennifer's iran's very
anti-tvs in the room so that disappeared
and we moved and started a new school
and
um
you know
we go to church and they love to go to
church every sunday but they didn't do
that before and we used to have
unlimited screen time and we don't do
that anymore and like
just
big big life changes um can i and i i
want to throw one out there that i want
to make sure we don't blow by okay
um
their mom left them
oh i know so
regardless of the the sea change if we
don't do it we don't do entertainment
like this or it's not free reign here
there's new rules in 10 there's new
sheriff in town
that's all
stuff that's fine like their environment
their mama left them
right so when you say like their life's
for the better i would say it's super
not now maybe the structure in their
life and all that's better but their mom
looked at him and said i'd rather go do
something else than y'all you see what
i'm saying so
major trauma major like i think one of
the core traumas a person can experience
right mom leaving them so i
100 agree and i'm gonna tell you more
trauma that she keeps piling up okay
okay all right
um
okay so
we have had problems with our oldest
from
kind of the beginning like first it
started with i can't sleep well yep you
know this is a kid that like
got straight a's very you know
rule follower kind of kid can't sleep
um she's also
probably on the spectrum but she also
got diagnosed this year with conversion
disorder
and what what what have you all done as
parents
to
rally around this young woman
we have
we've
spent time together we've i mean we've
talked
are like tried to listen try to be like
what feelings are going on what
situations we've gone to
at least two counselors maybe more
um
we
anyway like
more and more and more uh y'all put in
the effort that's what i'm just getting
at that y'all you're trying okay
on may 1st
our oldest attempted suicide so our kid
just got out of a mental hospital not
very long ago her mother who they see
periodically
um
now has
a nasty but home where they can go um
has had a relationship now two years ago
she told our oldest that she was
in a polyamorous relationship okay which
you know exacerbated things also but now
it was like
why did why did that exacerbate things
okay so
boy long distance polyamorous boyfriend
is now moving in okay
so there are going to be two
boyfriends living in the house
and i might i didn't mention this but my
younger daughter
um she has been to the counseling also
has attachment disorder tends to be
very
super friendly with men like
inappropriately friendly because she's
so desperate for attention we're
terrified our kids are going
to be
molested
we are not okay with our kids going to
stay at this house anymore okay
um we don't know how to talk about this
in a way
that
i mean
that says
let me we don't want you to hate your
mom we want you to love your mom as best
you can but
putting you in a dangerous situation yes
so here's a
i'm gonna make some broad assumptions
okay and feel free to interrupt me and
tell me if i'm wrong
okay
um how long have you and your husband
been married
it will be five years at the end of this
month okay all right
yeah i wrote that down five years so
in the last five years and particularly
the last three years
the world has unspooled on all of us
particularly on y'all
yeah and you have had a ringside seat
to a beautiful young 12 year old who is
now a struggling beautiful
17 year old
yes oh did i mention i also had a baby
in this time might as well why not let's
just make this more chaotic
yeah and as a parent you're watching
this happen as you're watching a
slow-motion
car crash
and you're doing what you can
is what you what you know to do
and at the same time you've got another
little one who was 10 at the time who's
now 15
who i i don't like saying kids are
desperate for attention
i like saying they are desperate for
love
right okay i mean and i mean whatever
you want to say well and here's what
yeah if someone's like just desperate
for attention like i'm like shut up go
away
if i see some kid who is desperate for
connection
that's a totally different thing
right that's somebody asking me for air
or asking me for a sip of water that's a
different thing
than i just want to be the center of
attention right right okay so
as a parent
as somebody who feels like they're
losing control of everything
it is real easy
to try to gain control in as many ways
as you can in all the other areas where
you think you can drill down
i will tell you
that
um
it is a hundred percent in you and your
husband's right
to want to know
who else is in the home of the ex from
or in any home where my kids happen to
be
period right if it's if it's a friend's
house if it's um
a cousin's house or if it's their
birth mom's home
and she happens to have two strange men
in the house
let's take the polyamory let's take the
fact that they're all dating let's take
that out that confuses it right because
that rolls us into our morals or our our
judgments and it makes everything more
chaotic than it needs to be okay let's
move that over for a second
and let's just say there are two strange
dudes in that house and i got two
teenage daughters i'm not sending them
into that
the idea that because they are all
dating
means they're more likely to sexually
assault and molest a child isn't
accurate
i've never read that data anywhere
and i want to be careful not to lob
grenades like that because here's why it
muddies the case for
um
it starts adding
variables and judgments to places that
don't need them
now i don't think it's wise
i think it's ill-advised and i would
tell anybody this with love in my heart
to have two live-in boyfriends that
you're sleeping with at the same time
that's a recipe for disaster okay it
just is
um
and it's okay as parents to say i don't
want i don't want my kids getting of
that
model as an alternative presentation of
what love looks like that's okay
but to suggest then and they're probably
molesters that's that's where the whole
argument your kids are going to roll
their eyes here's a good example if you
tell your kids
if you drink a beer you know what
happens cancer and death
in drunk driving and then the one time
they sneak a beer and they wake up the
next morning and they're they're
still alive what they do right then that
moment is they say i wonder what else
they lied to me about
and so i have to tell my kids who are 12
and 6. sex is incredible it's awesome
and it's not for 12 and six year olds
and then i insert i tell them my values
right so
here's the
back out of the polyamory thing
a hundred percent y'all should be bold
and feel really good
about saying i am not going to put my
kids in a situation where there's
revolving men in a home or two strange
men if those two men want to come meet
me and my husband for lunch and we're
going to talk through what this looks
like cool but otherwise i'm not doing
that
and i'll go to court over it and i'll
fight you over fill parches in the
parachute we'll fill in the blank okay
right we'll have that conversation and
then in a separate conversation
with my 17 year old and of course my 15
year old
i would absolutely have the conversation
here's how we think love should work
and here's what a healthy relationship
looks like
um we don't agree with your mom's
decision to have two live-in boyfriends
and try to make a uh what they call it a
throuple i think this is the word like
to try to make that work um
that's not something that we think is
wise
and
we're not going to talk bad about your
mom so we want we want you all to know
we are intentionally modeling what we
think a healthy a healthy romantic
relationship looks like and that's where
you can leave it being distraught and
raged out will not change the situation
yeah what here's what will happen though
your kids will absorb that tension and
they will think it's their fault
because they will connect the dots that
every time they go to mom's house
stepmom and dad get crazy
it must be us
and every time i come over here and go
back the other way it's a little bit
quieter
birth mom doesn't care so it must be
safe forever you see what i'm saying
and so i want to i mean we don't i i
know you don't i don't know
i know yeah no we it's that it's that
you don't want them to
to have all of that yeah and so i think
it's identifying we choose to to live
healthy relationships this way because
and you and your husband may have never
had that conversation you may just be
like i'm not having uh my husband's not
bringing in a living girlfriend with us
y'all may have not sat down and said hey
here's what we think a healthy
relationship looks like are we modeling
that
that's a
killer conversation to have with a 17
year old and a 15 year old and a 12 year
old that's a great conversation to have
yeah and then tell them hold us
accountable if you don't see us doing
that
great and now we're going to start
entering into that conversation and when
their mother's situation falls apart
which 100 chance it will and the
internets are going to get mad at me for
saying that it will the chances of them
all being 92
two 92 year old dudes and her living out
their best like riding off into the
sunset together are zero they're just
zero right um yeah no and i think he's
like he just graduated from college so
like
we're 40 and i think he's 25. excellent
excellent excellent so
when this falls apart which it will yeah
what your kids do not need is that i
told you so they don't need it
right they need a picture of stability
that's been that's existed the entire
time
that's what i mean and that's what you
can offer them
not the i no man
and be real clear with mom
i'm not just gonna have strange dudes
coming over the house not with my 15
year old daughter and my 17 year old
daughter it's not gonna happen
and expect your daughters to put one in
one and one together and come up with
seven and say oh it's because you all
hate mom and you hate us
and we hate you we've already been down
that road that's right mom already
talked to the oldest about it that's
exactly right stay on your ground hold
your values yeah
and be a person of dignity and respect
if you feel your body getting fired up
and worked up say out loud i need to
take a minute
like this
the idea of putting you in an unsafe
situation hurts my heart and i need to
take a second and i'll circle back to
you and now i'm modeling what
frustration and healthy response that
frustration looks like to my teenage
daughters which is a gift that every
teenager needs
see what i'm saying this can be
this this mess of a situation which it
is
can be an extraordinary opportunity 10
years down the road
because now y'all are playing a long
game with these little ones right
uh what does mom say about the does she
say y'all are mean or crazy or abusive
what does she say or you're just not
progressive enough or what what what did
she say
um well
we kind of try to
i guess
the one conversation that i have heard
um
is that
she claims that
she is no longer involved with one of
the men
and that he's just a roommate now
and the other one is now her boyfriend
and she's been dating him for four years
this is a traditional relationship i
mean it was slightly untraditional when
she was dating both of them at the same
time but now it's just one and do you
see do you see how do you see how
getting into the middle of who's dating
who not it doesn't matter who cares oh
yeah yeah i'm just out of that i don't i
don't want to know anything that's right
i don't want to keep up with it i don't
want to know about here's what i know
i'm not going to put my daughters in a
situation where there's a cadre of men
that i don't know that i don't trust and
that i don't know have her best interest
at heart
full full stop and that's at school
that's at friend's house that's it
ex-wife's house and i'll take you to
court over it i'll spend money over it
but we're not doing this right that is
totally different and we're going to
talk about values in our home like i
would expect anybody to talk about their
values right
right and so all the time like i i think
it's super important to to put out there
and not just assume they're gonna absorb
it okay i want you to hang on to what
i'm about to say and and um hang on to
this
i want you to provide
a living breathing reality
that shows why
the way you and your husband choose to
do adult relationships
is a better alternative
and you won't provide that by yelling
and screaming nothing that you do but
you won't provide that by becoming a
taser you're going to provide that by
having a home that feels safe and a home
that feels warm and patience and being
kind and standing up when you just stand
up by standing up in a way that's
under control and honorable
not one of i can't take it anymore
that's something that children can
anchor into
and i hear and
this isn't you and i'm just
extrapolating this broadly to people
listening
i heard this recently i maybe even
talked about the show um somebody said
what if instead of yelling all the time
trying to burn down everything that we
don't agree with
we just created such incredible
alternatives we built such incredible
things that it rendered the other stuff
obsolete
and if i double down on how good my
marriage can be
and i create a space between me and my
wife that allows my kid to anchor into
that my two kids to anchor into that and
that they can't wait to get home just
because it feels safe it's not a charged
environment
and where we listen to them and we hold
them accountable we do all that stuff
together
they're going to lean into that safety
they're going to lean into that
because it's peaceful
right that's the fruit there
and so
instead of worrying about ah that's good
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna show you
here's what this looks like and that's
how people's hearts are gonna change and
that's gonna allow your kids to
[Music]
and don't forget those girls are going
to be doing whatever they can for a long
long time
[Music]
to figure out what they did wrong
that made mom leave
and the best you can do is walk
alongside them and say you're enough
you're enough you're enough and they're
going to do any number of things to try
to prove to mom that they're worth being
loved
and they're going to need you in their
ear
you're enough you're enough
i love you you're enough
we'll be right back
hey what's up delony here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
delony that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we are
back let's see here let's go
actually no
oh hey if y'all wanna know how the show
actually works it's that
kelly coming in going actually no
we decided that since we have to sit
here and listen who's we
the collective
control room oh the board people yes
okay um that
we have to sit here and listen to this
so occasionally we should get
to ask a question
we have to
that we should get to ask a question if
we have questions about you know the
fall within the
the topics so
nathan we literally were hanging all
right let's do it i know but nathan has
a great question that we thought was
excellent and worth being on the air all
right let's do it what's up by the way
nathan is the youtube guru he runs all
these cameras and switches them and
lights and everything it's good to see
it man okay
what's up
all right so we have metrics for
physical health when it comes to heart
rate calories weight all that stuff how
do we track
when we know that we have become
mentally healthy
do you have an example of that
um
i've got an example of that
like how do you know when you get there
wherever like like you okay so
let me see if this is what you're asking
if you wanted to you're a pretty buff
guy but you're like i want to put on 25
more pounds of raw american beef muscle
right and you went to the gym
and you lifted a lot you would have a
scale and you would have a number of
workouts that you did and you would be
able to say i made this goal or i didn't
make this goal
but when you
and your wife are like we want to be
mentally well we want to have good
mental health
what is like how do we know when we got
there is that what you're asking yeah so
it's like if you're in
if you know you're not in a good place
in your mental health
and you start that process of becoming
mentally healthy how do you know when
you've gotten to a place where you are
ah okay all right so i think it's
important that's a great question man
good call you should have called into
the show that's great
um okay so here's my answer to that just
off top of my head number one
um
mental health is a process it's a it's a
state of doing it is not a destination
um you will never get to
like i'm mentally well like there's not
people yelling that on rooftops
um
it's a process because the moment you
think like oh i'm great that's when you
walk out in the parking lot and somebody
texts you and says hey mom's got cancer
that's when you find out your friend
just got a car wreck right that's
life happens over and over and over
again
so dealing with those things up and down
up and down doesn't mean you're not
mentally healthy right or mentally well
so mental health is a process it's a
thing that you do it's not a destination
you can never quote unquote get there
um
here's that interesting thing i was just
talking to somebody about this the other
day so
part of me unspooling back in 2008 2009
was my i grew up um we had a lot of
financial challenges growing up my dad
was just a police officer we i think we
made like 22 grand we didn't make a lot
of money and we struggled a lot
financially growing up
so i have a built-in narrative that my
body responds to that
money
is is a trigger across the board for me
it just always has been
2008 and 2009 i was coming into my own
as a young professional i was over
things having to deal with budgets for
the first time in personnel for the
first time
and everything fell apart right and i
just bought another house and everything
in the country fell apart so i was
listening to students come from all over
the country and their parents were going
to pull them out of school and people's
home equities were falling apart it was
just a mess and my body responded as
though this the apocalypse is upon us
right
and that came out as anxiety that came
out as extreme ocd that came out of
seasons of running really low and being
burned out i've always had adhd so any
diagnosis you could throw at it man i
was all over the place
the journey out of that
so now we're entering into right to
enter into a recession inflation's crazy
there's economic issues everywhere
i was just talking to someone the other
day
after a decade of
learning how to sleep
learning the importance of having
friends and making that a regular
priority the importance of having a
daily exercise routine being conscious
of what i eat and what i put into my
head right whether that's if i just
listen to pantera 24 7 i'm going to be a
little more of an angry guy right um
if uh if i watch the news 24 7 i'm gonna
be raged out i'm gonna it's gonna spin
my my brain up
so
the process of me getting well has just
been a continuation so the facts
haven't changed the economy is a mess
and it's about to get gnarly for a
season here's how i know i am on a path
of wellness my body's not reacting as
though it's the end of time does that
make sense
and so when somebody says how do i know
if i'm mentally well if i'm healthy
can your body hear
can your body hear these stories can
your body be faced with reality
and can it respond a spot respond
appropriately is that fair does that
make sense
so if my wife gets in a car wreck today
and passes away
i don't want to put that in the universe
but let's say that happens an
appropriate response from my body will
be to shut down in the black hole of
grief for a long time
and have to deal with two little kids
and all that stuff that would be
appropriate
the
process of dealing with inflation
economy whatever now i'm going to deal
with it and my body's not taking off i
mean i'm going to deal with it with the
facts i have in front of me and i'm just
going to live that way
and i'm going to keep doing doing the
things that helped me be well does that
answer your question is that helpful
yeah yeah
i feel like i talk around do that i
don't know you're laughing kelly that's
like so this doesn't do great no i
thought that was great okay
um how do you know when you're mentally
well
on those rare rare moments
when that happens
i think um
it's when i feel that i've
kind of what you said when i feel like
i've responded
not even to a crisis because you know
just life just life appropriately
because you know when you don't respond
appropriately you know and you're like
wow that was way out of line yeah when i
feel like i've responded appropriately
and also when i
a lot with me is when i feel like i'm
doing okay when i can say well i messed
that up or
i know i apologize to my kids because i
acted you know i yelled when i shouldn't
have or whatever so so it's really
trying to keep my body out of fight or
flight whenever possible right or only
going into fight or flight when
necessary right
and yeah that's that tells me that's the
metric if you will that i'm on the path
and i do think some of the metrics like
for heart rate variability they tell me
if my body's functioning okay the scale
is but one data point that tells me
hey man it's higher than it was
that tells me you're you're not you're
heading off into the past it's great man
that's good data point that makes it so
all these data points they still work
but there's no end goal to quote unquote
mental health it's a daily it's a it's a
daily path that we walk right does that
make sense
and you've got four kids so
good luck with that
good luck with that hey thanks for the
question man you should call into the
show you should work on this show man
i'm just kidding i'm glad you're here
you give
yeah that's all i'll say
none of this happens without that dude
we'll be right back
hey delony here one of the things i love
about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book i will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the new roads of a well life
moving forward go to johndaloni.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show who
picked these lyrics kelly's
her third favorite band she has a bunch
of bands tattooed all over her the one
that's tattooed right above she's got
like that old sun right in her lower
back the tattoo right above that sun
you said it not me is uh her her third
favorite band paramore
and um the song is fake happy
and it goes like this
i love making you believe what you get
is what you see but i'm so fake happy
i feel so fake happy and i bet everybody
here is just as insincere we're all so
fake happy
i know i'm fake happy
so i've been doing a good job of making
them think i'm quite all right better
hope i don't blink you see it's easy
when i'm stomping on a beat but no one
sees me when i crawl back underneath if
i smile with my teeth i bet you believe
me
if i smile with my teeth i think you
believe me
hey stop pretending
stop
stop playing fake hat
call somebody let them know you're not
all right we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode um i
actually do think you have the greatest
mental health podcast in the world yes
mom is this you run go do your laundry
my husband hasn't wanted to combine our
finances when i need groceries and
things for the baby i have to kind of
tell them like oh i need a hundred i
need fifty i need just for that you know
and just kind of little bit by little
bit ask for the things that i need emma
do you hear that that's madness he's
intimacy avoidant with me um you know
acts out regularly with
ex-girlfriends former affair partners he
has chosen
to continue a series of destructive
behaviors that are blowing up his life
and most importantly the one woman he
said was going to be his one woman